Musik Ich muss kurz meine Weckdokumente in meinen Sichtbereich schieben, dann ist alles gut, dann kann es losgehen, dann heißt es Podcast UFO 2016, geht los. Herzlich willkommen zur neuen Folge Podcast UFO 2016. Wir sind wieder am Start. Roboter haben nicht die Weltherrschaft an sich gerissen, das sind nur Gerüchte. 2016 ist ein ganz normales Jahr wie jedes anderes. Wow, und das trotz unseres Neujahrsvorsatzes, dass wir dieses Jahr keine Sendung machen wollten. Ja, wir haben leider unsere Vorsätze gebrochen, aber das war eigentlich unser einziger Vorsatz, unsere Vorsätze zu brechen. Moment mal, ich bin hier im Wald unterwegs, ich jogge hier gerade an knutschenden Rentnern vorbei, was ist das, was für Geräusche kommen mir hier entgegengeschwallt? Meine Damen und Herren, ich darf euch ganz herzlich begrüßen zur ersten Folge des Jahres 2016. Und natürlich ist bei mir heute wieder mit dabei, wir halten die Hände, wir umarmen uns, Steffen Titschler ist heute wieder bei uns dabei. Und natürlich wieder mit dabei, denn Namensgags werden irgendwann auch alt. Florentin Will, ich nenne diesen Namen. Vielen Dank, danke schön. Wir haben heute wieder die besten Punchlines von neuen Gags zusammengetragen und werden sie euch heute präsentieren und los geht's.
Erst mal ganz kurz, würde ich dir gerne ein frohes neues Jahr wünschen.
Ja, dankeschön, das wünsche ich dir auch.
Also und frohe Weihnachten, ich meine, wir haben uns, also ich muss sagen, ich habe dir sehr viele E-Mails und SMS und sehr viele Anrufe hinterlassen auf deiner Voicemail und auch relativ eindeindeutige Nachrichten mit vielen Herzchen und so. Und es kam nicht so viel zurück. Und ich bin gespannt, weil ich weiß, wenn nicht mehr zurückkommt, weiß ich, da ist irgendwas los. Da ist irgendwas im Florentine World, passiert irgendwas Spannendes. Es ist tatsächlich was passiert in meinem Leben, es sind gewisse Dinge geschehen. Und auch vielen Dank dafür, du warst der Einzige tatsächlich, der mir an Silvester um Punkt 12 Uhr geschrieben hat, frohes neues Jahr. Alles Gute zum Geburtstag, ja. Du hast mich Benedikt genannt, das war ein bisschen komisch, aber ansonsten war alles in Ordnung. Mann, Stefan, was ist los? Wir haben uns so lange nicht gehört, Mensch, das ist ja wirklich, es ist ja fast authentisch gerade, das Gespräch, weil wir uns wirklich lange nicht gehört haben und ich weiß gar nicht, was in deinem Leben so los ist, du hast nie Zeit, ich wollte eigentlich schon letzte Woche aufnehmen, weil die Leute schreiben, ja und ich dachte mir, klar, natürlich, wenn die Leute mehr wollen, dann geben wir ihnen mehr, ich habe dich angeschrieben. Das fand ich auch irgendwie eine Frechheit. Also Leute schreiben, ich brauche das Podcast-Ufo wieder, weil ich gerade am Lernen bin und ich muss vom Lernen abgehalten werden und so. Ja, Entschuldigung, ich muss auch zum Beispiel lernen und dann fiel mir heute ein, okay, vielleicht könnte ich mich selber davon ablenken, indem ich ein Podcast-Ufo aufnehme. Sehr gut. Fand ich jetzt nicht so schlecht, die Idee. Aber ich finde es total spannend. Es ist mir auch aus einem Verwandtenkreis aufgefallen. Man sagt immer Leuten, man gönnt Menschen einfach so eine Ruhepause. Man sagt Leuten eigentlich immer, ja, jetzt nimm dich mal ein bisschen zurück und nimm die mal frei, mach mal Pause, außer in der Unterhaltung. Da sagen alle direkt immer, die haben schon seit Wochen keinen Podcast mehr aufgenommen, das Projekt ist wahrscheinlich gestorben. Das stimmt, aber wir haben uns auch Ruhe gegönnt, glaube ich. Also wir haben beide uns mal ein bisschen zurückgelehnt, ein bisschen den Volume, ein bisschen ein paar ... Das Sprechen haben wir vergessen, mal einfach das Sprechen mal eingestellt für zwei Monate. Apropos Fans, mich hat gestern jemand angeschrieben, hey, du warst doch da bei Bonjour und dir ist da ein Wort nicht eingefallen.
Ist dir das Wort mittlerweile eingefallen?
Also, what?
Soll ich mich jetzt konkret daran erinnern, an das Wort, das mir nicht eingefallen ist?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das Wort war.
Das finde ich auch immer gut, wenn man, wenn man Fernschreiben irgendwie in Folge
neun habt ihr einen Gag liegen lassen
und dann irgendwas schreiben, was in meinem Kopf gar keinen
Sinn mehr ergibt. Ja, kannst du dich das noch
daran erinnern? Warte mal ganz kurz, ich muss den
Kommentar... War das der Kommentar der Woche?
Der Kommentar der Woche, ich würde direkt sofort
mit dem Kommentar der Woche anfangen. Wow, was ein
Ja! Es ist alles möglich. Ey, wir stürmen aus
dem Tor sofort raus, wir lassen
heute kein Auge trocken. Warte mal,
und zwar
bei Folge 15
Vielen Dank. Ja, es ist unmöglich. Wir stürmen aus dem Tor sofort raus, wir lassen heute kein Auge trocken. Warte mal, und zwar, genau, bei Folge 15 hat jemand geschrieben, Werner von Braun hatte nichts mit der Atombombe zu tun. Das waren aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht Oppenheimer und Fermi. Aber Folge 15, und jetzt liegen die Folgen so weit zurück, dass ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann, dass wir in Folge 15 eine ernsthafte und seriöse Diskussion über die Entwicklung der Atombombe hatten. Und ich würde es euch glauben. Ich würde es ihm glauben. Man fragt sich immer, wie ist man darauf gekommen und man kriegt die Gedanken, geht gar nicht mehr zusammen aus Dingen, die wir aus unserem Leben erzählen, irgendwelche lustigen Anekdoten, die wir uns krampfhaft überlegen während der Aufnahme und wie man dann auf Werner von Braun kommen kann. Oder auch heute hat er geschrieben, apropos in Folge 12 hat Florentin gesagt, dass die Goldpreise stabil bleiben, hat dann irgendwie so einen Graphen angehängt, wo die Goldpreise offensichtlich nicht stabil geblieben sind, was ich super geil finde. Ja, wo ich mir auch dachte, hatten wir mal so eine Investmentrubrik, wo wir Tipps geben, was man investieren soll, ich glaube schon. Die grosse Finans-Folge, ich meine, mich erinnern zu können. Aber das finde ich so geil. Das finde ich so geil, das ist wie, manchmal hat man das dasselbe, wenn man mit Leuten redet und dann fallen einem plötzlich Fakten ein, die ganz klar sind und ganz klar aussagen, dass der gegenüber gerade falsch liegt, aber es fällt einem nicht ein und so, und nach einer Woche oder nach einem Monat sagt man dem das einfach mal, dass er damals falsch lag. Und genau so ist es bei uns jetzt, weil Leute nehmen sich Zeit und irgendwann kommt so raus, dass wir einfach falsch schlagen manchmal und dann kommen die Fakten.
Ich finde das ganz schön, dass die Vergangenheit einfach flexibel ist, dass man sie verändern kann, dass sich seine Vergangenheit immer wieder weiter ändert.
Warum die Zukunft ändern?
Ich meine, wir waren ja wahrscheinlich beide über die Weihnachtszeit bei unseren Familien und haben natürlich auch da ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit gewühlt, ein bisschen Nostalgie, haben da auch ein paar Geschichten gehört aus der Kindheit, wo man sich dachte, wirklich, ist das so, habe ich das wirklich damals gemacht als Kind, aber man, das gehört auch mit dazu, dass man die Vergangenheit vergisst und neu erleben kann, das ist ja das Tolle an dem End. Ja, kannst du dich noch daran erinnern, dass ich, wo du gerade davon sprichst, ist mir gerade irgendwie eingefallen. Ich habe Weihnachten mal wieder tolle Gespräche geführt.
Wie gesagt, man kann ja auch so über seine Vergangenheit selber viel erfahren.
Ich habe ja zum Beispiel in einer Podcast-Folge, glaube ich, erzählt,
letzte vor Weihnachten, dass ich als Kindergartenkind wahnsinnig viel geschlafen habe.
Ja.
Und irgendwie kamen wir da Weihnachten nur darauf zu sprechen mit der ganzen Familie,
und dann plötzlich habe ich so Dinge erfahren wie, dass die Kindergärtnerin dann auch sogar irgendwie bei meiner Familie Bescheid gesagt hätte, dass ich das in den Griff bekommen sollte. So wird aus dem Jungen nichts, ganz ehrlich. Weil der verschläft wichtige Ereignisse irgendwie. Den Ausflug in den Zoo, da war der komplett nebensit. Das fand ich so lustig. Und ich dachte ja schon, dass ich ein bisschen übertrieben habe beim Erzählen, aber es hat sich herausgestellt, es war alles noch viel schlimmer. Und dann musste ich noch ein Jahr im Kindergarten bleiben, weil ich das nicht in den Griff bekommen habe mit dem Schlafproblematik einfach. Und deswegen war ich im Endeffekt ein Jahr länger im Kindergarten. Und dann als Maxikind habe ich das in den Griff bekommen, tatsächlich. Tolle Sachen, das erfährt man dann so, Weihnachten, alle sind gut drauf und dann wird man so runtergezogen durch so geile Storys über einen selbst. Mit den Kindergartengruppen hatten wir auch schon mal, ne? Was denn? In welchen Gruppen wir waren, weil bei uns im Kindergarten gab es drei Gruppen. Es gab die Drachen, die Dinosaurier und die Igel. Wo man sich auch so denkt, so cooles Level, na ja. Ich meine, man muss glaube ich nicht erwähnen, in welcher Gruppe ich war. Igel, geil, aber weil das auch so demütigend haben, haben Leute euch das irgendwie draußen gemobbt? Vor allem, vor allem, das war die Inklusionsgruppe. Ach ja, das hast du erzählt, ja. Ihr könnt nicht fliegen, ihr seid auch nicht riesengroß, ihr seid halt die Igel, ihr könnt euch einrollen. man das, einrollen?
Eigeln, einigeln, sagt man. Einigeln, sagt man, ja.
Ich habe tatsächlich gelernt, dass ich als Kind ein riesiger Angeber war, dass ich ein richtiges Arschloch war und dass ich immer behauptet hätte, ich könnte Dinge, die ich eigentlich noch gar nicht konnte. Ja, ich auch. Wie zum Beispiel, ich mal irgendwie bei Freunden von meiner Mutter war und die haben mir dann ein Buch geschenkt, so ein Kinderbuch, und dann meinte die so, ja, soll ich dir das Buch vorlesen? Und ich halt irgendwie als dreijähriger Kind so, nee, nee, ich kann lesen, kein Problem, ich kann schon selber lesen, halt komplett gelogen, einfach komplett geblufft, konnte kein Wort lesen und dann sie so, ach wirklich? Okay, dann liest du mir doch das Buch vor. Dann sass ich bei dieser Frau auf dem Schoss mit der Geschichte und meine Mutter meinte, ich hätte eine ganz fantastische, tolle, bahnbrechende Geschichte erzählt, nur halt nicht die, die im Buch steht, aber ich habe immer Story erzählt, umgeblättert, ja, und dann ist der Bär und hier und das, aber einfach komplett improvisiert. Auch wenn man als Kind denkt, man kommt damit durch. Gut, auch wenn die vielen Ams hätten darauf dissen können, dass du gerade nicht liest, aber naja. Genau, und vor allem die Geschichten, wo die ganzen Redaktionsnotizen waren, so da konnte man storymäßig noch nicht so viel ergeben, aber da habe ich auch schon angefangen. Und Widmung, ja, alles richtig gute Sachen. Naja, aber ich habe dieses Jahr, ich war ja auch Weihnachten, war ich auf Comedyfang, ganz ehrlich. Und wir waren mal wieder in der Kirche Weihnachten. Das Netz ausgeworfen. Und wir waren in der Kirche mal wieder Weihnachten und ich fand das, ich habe die ganze Zeit gewartet, also ich habe überlegt, wie viel Comedypotential steht eigentlich in so einem Gottesdienst, so einem Kindergottesdienst an Weihnachten?
Und die Antwort ist ein enormes, ja eigentlich. Es gibt ein Krippenspiel, jedes Jahr, wer kennt es nicht, die Mikrofonprobleme, wer kennt es nicht, das eine Kind, was irgendwie wahnsinnig schnell seinen Text loswerden will. Das Kind, das den Esel spielen muss. Genau, das Kind, was die Sterne hochhalten muss, ich war's. Und diese ganzen kleinen Dinge. Und es ist nichts passiert. Es lief alles glatt, die Geschichte war okay, es wurde eine Schnecke irgendwie hinzugedichtet. Die Figur einer Schnecke habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, kann aber ganz cool gewesen sein, keine Ahnung. Und dann ist es passiert. Ich weiß nicht, bist du katholisch oder bist du evangelisch? Ich bin römisch-katholisch. Und zwar gibt es dann diesen geilen Moment, wenn man vorne die Hostie bekommt. Ah ja. Und dann hat sich, ich sah es mittlerweile wieder, habe meine Hostie bereits empfangen und sah nur aus dem Augenwinkel, wie plötzlich so ein Mann so einen Tanz aufführte. Er hat einfach nur seine Hostie verloren, er hat die bekommen, Amen gesagt, da geht man ja einen Schritt zur Seite, um die dann zu essen und er hat die einfach verloren. Wo ich mir auch dachte, das ist das beste Zeichen Gottes. Das wird nichts Klausen, 2016 ist nicht ein Jahr. Das war ein Scheissjahr von dir. Und dann bestraft er einen, indem er die Hostie einfach fallen lässt. Und dann hat er die fallen gelassen und dann sah ich nur so einen Blick in Richtung Pfarrer, der aber einfach ihn ganz streng anguckte, weil es ist Leib Christi, du musst es dann auch essen. Du kannst es nicht einfach wegschmeißen. So funktioniert das nicht, mein Freund. Nee, und dann hat der Fahrrad ihn ganz streng anguckte und dann musste der das wirklich essen. Und ich war wirklich, ich war blendend drauf, den Gottesdienst, und dann gab es diesen Moment, da gibt es ja immer den Moment, wo man spenden soll. Und am feierlichen Anlässen, wie Weihnachten halt einer ist, liegen dann so kleine Tüten, diese Papiertüten, wo jeder halt Geld reinwerfen kann. Und das sind halt diese kleinen faltbaren Tüten. Und dann habe ich, dachte mir, komm, du haustest mal einen Mörder-Kirchen-Gag raus. Und dann habe ich gesagt, hm, sieht ein bisschen aus wie diese Papiertüten im Flugzeug. Also, falls einem das Krippenspiel nicht so ganz gefällt. Und niemand hat gelacht. Moment mal, zu welchem Publikum hast du das gesagt? Ich fand das ganz lustig. Hast du das einfach zu der dementen
Frau neben dir gedreht und einfach mal One-Liner
rausgehauen? Ja, korrekt. Ich habe mich zu der Familie
mit dem inklusionsbedürftigen Kind
aus der Igel-Gruppe hinter mir gedreht und
es kam keine Reaktion.
Humor funktioniert nicht
in Kirchen. Und das war, ich fand
den Gag nicht schlecht, so dass man das halt auf
Kotztüten ummünzt und sagt, falls einem das Krippenspiel nicht so ganz gefällt und niemand hat gelacht. Überhaupt keine Ahnung, von welchen Umschlägen du redest. Das ist nämlich der Klingelbeutel generell. Also die Prämie ist vielleicht ein bisschen holprig. Es sind so kleine Papiertüten, wie die im Flugzeug sind, nur halt zum Spenden. Es ist brilliant, wenn man das kennt. Wenn man das kennt, wäre es wahnsinnig lustig gerade auch. Ich würde dich hier echt gerne unterstützen, aber ich kenne es halt nicht. Aber es war wirklich lustig. Aber ich glaube, wir sind so weit mittlerweile im Jahr 2016, dass du mir vertrauen kannst, dass es wirklich ein wahnsinnig lustiger Gag ist. Du bist die eine Mannschaft, Volleyball hat kollektiv aufs Handy geschaut gerade, so Aufschlag und die anderen einfach nur aufs Handy, da passiert gar nichts, das Spiel funktioniert nicht. Aha, du trinkst wieder Tee, hat sich diese Tradition überlebt ins Jahr 2016? Ja, weißer Tee, Vanille-Piersig, Musstig einpacken, Superlust, das ist wirklich sehr lecker, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Du trinkst auch Tee, habe ich gehört? Ich trink auch Tee, New York Chai hat es mir heute mal angetan, tatsächlich, mit einem guten Löffel Honig. Das verstehe ich ja auch gar nicht. Also dieses Chai-Tee ist völlig an mir vorbeigegangen. Das ist plötzlich so ein Ding gewesen. Ja, aber es ist nicht wirklich Chai-Tee, weil klassischer Chai-Tee trinkt man ja mit Milch und das ist eigentlich so die Billow-Variante, dann dieses Pfanner oder wie auch immer diese Tee-Marken heißen springen dann da auf und es ist alles so ein bisschen Billow, aber New York hat mich gecatcht einfach, so dieses Feeling, dass da dabei ist. Es geht nicht so sehr um den Geschmack, es geht um das Feeling tatsächlich. Aber da hatten wir auch schon mal drüber geredet, dass Dinge durch ihren ideellen Wert besser sind. Ich habe zum Jahresumschwung alles vergessen, was davor passiert ist. Das heißt, wir können alles nochmal rausholen tatsächlich. Ganz kurz, nee, mal ganz kurz, wir wagen mal einfach einen Blick in die
Zukunft, ja, weil wir haben ja angefangen
als Podcast-Welpen, ja, wir sind da so
rausgekullert irgendwie aus dem Beutel
der Comedy und jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen
gehen gelernt und jetzt sind wir schon so,
jetzt können wir uns schon das eine oder andere scharf
kümmern. Du hast einige heiße Projekte
am Start, ich habe einige heiße Projekte am Start.
Wie schaut's aus, Antenne Alderaan, wie läuft's?
Ach, ganz gut, also ich muss sagen, seit deiner Erwähnung hier im UFO, mega geil. Also es war wirklich, ich glaube, die Kategorie Film und Fernsehen, wie heißt die, TV und Film bei iTunes, glaube ich, ist sehr unterrepräsentiert, weil wir waren irgendwie drei Wochen auf Platz eins. Durch, würde ich sagen, 30 Hörer oder so, die dann gekommen sind. Was ja nicht wenig ist und was auch schön ist, aber es ist einfach krass, wie schnell man in der Kategorie auf Platz eins ist. Und deswegen sollten wir uns vielleicht irgendwie, weiss ich, Kategorie Erotik oder so, halt einfach eine andere Kategorie nehmen als Comedy. Hart umkämpft, glaube ich, so was in der Richtung. Kann sein, aber passt auch irgendwie. Jetzt mal du als Experte, darf man denn jetzt schon spoilern über Star Wars Episode sieben? Ja. Weil ich habe tatsächlich, als wir in der letzten Folge über Star Wars geredet haben, ist mir eine Beobachtung so auf der Zunge gebrannt, aber die impliziert einen Spoiler. Deswegen wollte ich sie nicht bringen. Bringen sie, muss man. Deswegen bringe ich sie jetzt, wo man spoilern kann. Und zwar, jeder, der in Star Wars Episode 7 noch nicht gesehen hat, kann jetzt sterben gehen. Also, Luke Skywalker tritt ja ganz am Ende des Films auf, hat aber keinen Text. So, und jetzt gab es ja im Vorhinein der Vermarktung von Star Wars Episode VII ganz viele Interviews, unter anderem auch mit den deutschen Synchronsprechern von Han Solo, Princess Leia und Luke Skywalker, die immer interviewt wurden, so, hey, wie war das denn nochmal, in die alten Rollen hineinzuschlüpfen? Und da saßen zwei Menschen, die tatsächlich an dem Projekt mitgearbeitet haben und bezahlt wurden, und ein Mensch, der nicht mal im Aufnahmestudio war, der überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hat, der aber trotzdem zu jedem Pressetermin eingeladen wurde. Und noch immer was gesagt hat, im meisten Redeanteil hatte. Und immer wieder sagen musste, ja, natürlich die alten Charaktere, es war war schon interessant sich da mal noch mit ihnen auseinanderzusetzen
und sie reden gerade mit einem Mann der nichts mit diesem Projekt zu tun hat und es gibt nichts schöneres als sich jetzt im Nachhinein diese ganzen Interviews anzuschauen das stimmt und es ist ja in jedem Land der spanische Synchronsprecher von Luke Skywalker, der italienische, jeder einzelne Fucking hat sich gedacht Ja scheisse, ich muss jetzt hier einfach mich ein Jahr oder eineinhalb Jahre lang durch die gesamte PR des Films bluffen.
Einfach, weil ich darf es ja niemandem sagen, dass ich kein Wort gesagt habe.
Aber warum? Erstmal, es ist nicht ganz richtig, weil der hat einen Trailer gesprochen. Aber das war es glaube ich auch schon.
Aber auch die deutsche Stimme?
Ja.
Ah, okay.
Aber trotzdem.
Da fick dich doch.
Naja, es wäre halt kein Grund, die trotzdem einzuladen. Da würde mich mal interessieren, wie denn die Entscheidungskette da war. Also haben die selber gesagt, ich setze mich jetzt dazu, ich meine, ich bin der fucking Synchronsprecher von Luke Skywalker. Oder hat irgendwie Disney oder J.J. Abrams gesagt, setzt euch da gefälligst hin, weil es ist ja schon eine ganz geile Art, das Publikum zu verarschen. Ja, weil man kann ja, ich weiss nicht, ob die jetzt einen Vertrag unterzeichnen mussten, dass sie nichts sagen oder dass sie das selbstständig gemacht haben, weil ohne weiteres hätten die ja einfach das sagen können.
Ja, ich war gar nicht beteiligt beim Projekt, was ja schon ein Spoiler gewesen wäre.
Vor allem, ich weiß auch nicht, woran das, also irgendwer hat glaube ich damals, als wir in Rocket Beans waren, wo wir den Trailer geguckt haben und wo wir wahnsinnig wissend getan haben, da hat einer gesagt, dass Mark Hamill wahnsinnig viele Drehtage hatte.
Ja, genau. Und seitdem brannte das irgendwie in meinem Hirn. Und auch während des Screenings dachte ich die ganze Zeit, ja, Moment mal, Luke, hallo, wo bist du denn gerade? Er hat ja als Tonassistent geholfen, das muss er nicht heißen als Schauspieler. Keine Ahnung. Passt ja schon. Ich wusste es nicht, und dann kam er einfach ganz am Ende erst. Und ich dachte mir dann auch, das ist ein bisschen so eine Hitchcock-Nummer eigentlich. Der hat ja damals auch für die Frau Bates damals irgendwie einen Regiestuhl bauen lassen, damit alle dachten, dass es zwei Rollen gibt und dass es nicht auch Norman Bates ist. Und dann hat er, glaube ich, auch so ein... Spoiler! Ja mein Gott. Und dann musste der, hat er auch, glaube ich, damals die meisten Bücher, die es zu dem Film gab, aufgekauft, damit möglichst wenige den Plottwist am Ende erfahren. Was halt total geil ist. Er hat natürlich keine Chance, irgendwie durch seine 20 Bücher, die er gekauft hat, irgendwie was zu ändern. Aber es ist halt geil, dass sie diesen Willen entwickeln, da was, auf jeden Fall noch so das Publikum überraschen zu können.
Und das fand ich bei J.J. Abrams auch ganz geil,
wenn er halt irgendwo dieses Wissen implantiert hat,
dass Luke Skywalker so viele Drehtage hatte.
Finde ich mir ja gut.
Hitchcock hat auch aktiv versucht, die Leute davon abzuhalten,
ins Kino zu gehen, um den Film zu sehen,
einfach damit sie nicht gespoilert werden,
einfach damit zu sagen, nein, ich leg mich jetzt hier vor den Kinosaal, ihr dürft da nicht rein, ihr dürft das Geheimnis nicht lüften.
Ich kann sagen, das war der beste Gag, den wir 2016 gemacht haben. Dankeschön, es hat nur 18 Minuten gedauert. Aber ich möchte mal ganz kurz eine Ansage machen an alle Leute da draußen, die uns zuhören. Leute, wenn ihr in diesen Podcast eingeladen werden wollt, als Gast, dann schreibt uns einfach an, schreibt uns eine Mail, schreibt uns auf Facebook, aber wir müssen jetzt echt nicht mit dieser Kinderkacke anfangen, dass man sich jetzt irgendwelche ausgedachten Preise gegenseitig gibt, nur wenn man sich nicht traut, uns anzusprechen und damit man einen Podcast eingeladen wird. Medien-Coup, ich glaube, ihr wisst, wer gemeint ist an der Stelle. Ich glaube, wir sind erwachsene Leute, wir können miteinander sprechen. Ihr müsst euch jetzt nicht irgendwelche halbgaren Medienpreise ausdenken und uns verleihen, nur damit wir auf euch aufmerksam werden. Okay, ich glaube, das ist ein Alter, aus dem sind wir alle raus. Möchte ich jetzt nur mal ganz kurz... Und damit wollen wir bekannt geben, wir haben die Medien-Coup gewonnen. Yes! Medien-Coup! In your face, Nils Ruf! In your face, Charlotte! Ach, wie hat das Scheiße, Mann, ey. Fuck, Mann, Schreiner, nee. Engelhardt. Engelhardt? Weiß ich nicht, wie du meinst. Egal, aber wir haben es geschafft. Wir haben unseren ersten Preis, unser erster Preis. Ich meine, wir haben damit nichts gerechnet und dann plötzlich kommt aus dem Nichts der Preis plötzlich.
Und ich meine, wir haben ja, ich muss sagen, wir haben schon so ein bisschen, also man würde es, wenn man in Richtung Oscar arbeitet, würde man es Oscar-Baiting nennen. Wir haben schon so ein bisschen Median-Coup-Baiting betrieben. Wir wussten schon, was denen gefällt, haben so ein bisschen in die Richtung gearbeitet. Und jetzt kriegen wir den Preis. Im Nachhinein auch zugeben, dass wir extra sehr gute Folgen gemacht haben, um den Preis zu gewinnen.
Sorry, wir lösen jetzt alles auf, es war alles ein bisschen besser als... Richtung gearbeitet. Und jetzt kriegen wir den Preis. Im Nachhinein auch zugeben, dass wir extra sehr gute Folgen gemacht haben, um den Preis
zu gewinnen. Sorry, wir lösen jetzt alles
auf, es war alles ein bisschen besser als gedacht.
Entschuldigung an der Stelle, aber ich kann mich
noch genau erinnern, ich war in meiner
Heimat unterwegs, ich bin mit dem Auto meiner Mutter
durch den Wald gefahren, plötzlich
vibriert mein Handy, alles klingt,
Leuchte an, Scheibenwischer geht an,
Türen gehen auf, ja, alles passiert
um mich herum, das ist hier los. Das warenblinkliches Airbag, Das Airbag geht los. Das ist hier los, ich hatte einen Unfall tatsächlich. Nicht so schön, aber drei Tage später kam dann eine SMS von dir und die hat mich wieder so ein bisschen aufgeheitert, weil da tatsächlich stand, wir haben die Medienkuh gewonnen und das ist erst mal so ein Ding, wo ich mir dachte, wow, oft weiss man ja gar nicht, dass man Dinge will, bis man sie hat. Ne, andersrum, man will sie, bis man sie hat. Ach, scheiße, egal. Auf jeden Fall freuen wir uns sehr darüber. Vielen Dank an Stefan Herm und Thomas Wojcek an dieser Stelle. Vielen Dank für diesen Preis, dass ihr uns auserwählt habt. Dankeschön, bis zum nächsten Mal. Wir sollten vielleicht auch einen Preis einführen, das Goldene UFO, das dann jedes Jahr Cordula kriegt, ist vielleicht ein bisschen langweilig, aber vielleicht können wir uns was anderes ausdenken. Ja, aber finde ich ganz gut. Also so einen Preisverleihen, finde ich jetzt nicht schlecht. Aber die Frage ist an wen oder auch wofür. Wir können auch einen Negativpreis verleihen, weil ich glaube, wir sind Wendern so Meter, wir würden einen Negativpreis verleihen. Oder so einen mittelmässigen Preis. Die mittelmässigste Person 2016. Du warst okay. So, die überhaupt nicht aufgefallen ist. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber die, die vielleicht nicht aufgefallen ist, aber auch jetzt nicht scheiße war oder gar nicht da war, sondern die war einfach okay. Die einfach ihr Ding gemacht hat, das ist doch nicht schlecht. Die mittelmässigste Person 2016. Wir nehmen ab jetzt Vorschläge an, schreibt in die Kommentare bei uns bei Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, Snapchat, Pinterest, Tinder, wie ihr auch immer wollt, schreibt uns Vorschläge für und die mittelmässigste Person, das mittelmässigste Produkt und das mittelmässigste Ereignis. 2016, wir nehmen ab jetzt Vorschläge an, könnt ihr alles schreiben. Und trotzdem auch bestes Musical, beste Comedy. Beste Schausauspielerin einer Nebenrolle, das kommt natürlich auch dazu, wie immer, ist ja klar. Das ist nicht Golden Globes gesehen gestern. Nein, ich wollte so lange wach bleiben und bin dann pünktlich um zwei Uhr eingeschlafen. Aber mein Gott, ich meine... Aber auch dein Unterbewusstsein hat es sehr genossen. Ich habe im Nachhinein noch die Ricky Gervais Monologues gesehen und fand die ziemlich geil. Ja, Ist natürlich ein guter Typ. Weil ich auch geil finde, dass die Golden Globes sich anscheinend so egal sind, dass sie so einen Ricky Gervais dahinstellen, der einfach nur die ganze Zeit den Golden Globes fertig macht. Was in Deutschland unvorstellbar wäre, dass der Host die ganze Zeit auf der Preisversorgung rumstampft, dafür Geld bekommt und im nächsten Jahr wieder eingeladen wird. Dieses Bewusstsein muss sich bei uns durchsetzen. Lass uns auch eine Preisverleihung veranstalten und auch Ricky Gervais. Wir machen eine absolute Preisverleihung. Wir machen die Preisverleihung, eine mittelmässigste, wir brauchen nur noch einen guten Namen. Der goldene Nils Ruf. Machen wir denn so kleine Statuetten von Nils Ruf? Vielleicht, vielleicht fällt euch was besseres ein. Schreibt es doch mal, schreibt es in die Puffopedia oder wo auch immer, die ja tatsächlich sehr, sehr floriert und blüht und immer weiter wächst. Vielen Dank, wir sehen das mit großen Augen. Ich glaube ja immer, dass sich die erste künstliche Intelligenz im Internet entwickelt. Durch sowas wie Wikipedia oder Google, wo immer mehr Informationen reinkommen, dass sich sozusagen eigene künstliche Intelligenz entwickelt.
Und ich habe mittlerweile das Gefühl, dass wenn sich die irgendwann mal im Internet entwickelt, dann in der Puffopedia. Und es wird so eine ganz unangenehme Intelligenz, die so einen ganz unangenehmen Charakter hat. Die immer so ein bisschen zu nahe kommt, immer so ein bisschen okay. Ja, aber auch so Shield, eigentlich so ein Augenpflaster. Man weiss nie genau, wo man hingucken soll. So uncool so ein bisschen, dir gefällt auch komische Filme und sowas, das ist ein ganz unangenehmer Typ. Und deren Glas Cola immer ein bisschen zu voll ist, immer so, wo man sich denkt, das ist zu voll, was machst du da, so Kleinigkeiten. Ja, immer ein bisschen, was Ziel hinausschießt. Was ich ja total lustig finde, ich interessiere mich ja mega für das Thema Zeitreise. Ich auch! Und ich habe den Film. Ah, das ist ja ein Zufall hier. Und ich habe den Film Looper gesehen.
Nein, ach Gott, hier, ist es nicht mit Hayden Christensen? Nein, das ist Jumper. Aber es ist ähnlich vom Prinzip, aber ein doch viel besserer Film. Ja, der arme, Hayden Christensen tut mir ein bisschen leid, auch wenn er in New Yorker Love You noch mitgespielt hat, guter Film. Der ist auch, glaube ich, ein guter Schauspieler. Na, weiss ich nicht. Ja gut, okay, es ist schwer zu bewerten, weil George Lucas es einfach schafft, das Schlechteste aus jedem Menschen rauszukriegen, auch Natalie Portman, Oscar-Preistelleren, hat einfach grottenschlecht gespielt. Deswegen ist es schlecht, sein Debüt der Größenöffentlichkeit unter der Fuchtel von George Lucas zu haben. Bisschen kritisch, bisschen schwierig. Jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr genau, wo ich hin wollte. Wo hatten wir denn? Zeitreisen, du liebst Zeitreisen. Und zwar, ich dachte mir nämlich, warum ist noch niemand auf den Gag gekommen, also Vorwurf jetzt an die Community, dass man, weil wir haben einen Eintrag für jede Folge. Was du nicht wisst, jeder Gag ist auch ein Vorwurf an euch. Also, und zwar, warum ist noch niemand auf die Idee gekommen, Einträge für zukünftige Folgen zu machen? Zumal wir diesen Gag auch schon mal in Beschreibungstexten angewandelt haben. Richtig, jetzt einfach
setzt euch mal einfach heute hin
und macht den Eintrag für Folge 57
und schreibt genau rein, welche
Zitate, welche Gags, was passiert,
worüber wir reden. Mega lustig, weil
dann kommen wir nämlich in dieses Paradoxon,
ob wir es dann tatsächlich
machen, weil das ist ja das Geniale,
warum ich auch nicht weiß,
warum das kein Zeitreisefilm macht, weil stell dir mal vor, du hast eine Zeitmaschine und jetzt sagst du, okay, in einer Stunde fliegen wir jetzt zurück zur französischen Revolution und spielen irgendwie All the Single Ladies auf dem grossen Marktplatz in Paris, wo gerade alle Leute hingerichtet werden, machen wir das da. So dass er in den Geschichtsbüchern steht, wo dieses grosse Ereignis steht und dann in seinem Nebensatz übrigens zwei vollidiotenspielten Single Ladies, bevor es Beyoncé später sang.
Richtig, und wir schliessen, wir machen das in eine Stunde, schauen jetzt aber in einem Geschichtsbuch nach, ob das da schon drinsteht. Weil wenn wir es tatsächlich machen würden, würde es da ja schon drinstehen, weil es ja schon passiert war. Aber wenn das da drinsteht, können wir uns aber immer noch entscheiden, nicht in einer Stunde in die Vergangenheit zu reisen und damit das komplette Universum implodieren zu lassen, weil dann Dinge passiert sind, die nicht passiert sind. Ja, das Spannendste an einem Zeitreisen-Film ist ja immer, dass es nicht funktionieren kann. Ist der unbichtige Nebendarsteller mit dem Obststand, der immer umgerannt wird. Der lustige Sidekick. Ja, das sind die Endcredits. Nein, aber ganz im Ernst, ich versuche mal kurz zu erklären, warum Zeitreisen nicht möglich sind. Das ist was wahnsinnig Anspruchsvolles. Ich hoffe, dass es zu schätzen weist, wenn es hinhaut. Also, angenommen, ich reise später zu meinem jetzigen Ich und sage mir etwas, was ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht weiß, was ich nur durch diesen Prozess gewusst haben konnte. Zum Beispiel, er sagt mir einen Satz wie E ist gleich MC Quadrat, wenn ich das zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht wusste. So, dann weiß ich das, mein späteres Ich weiß das ja nur, weil eriss, dass damals jemand gekommen ist, der ihm das gesagt hat. Das heisst, man kann Dinge aus sich selber erschaffen. Aber es ist ja schon passiert. Also du kannst Dinge wissen, obwohl du die nie weisst, ja. Aber du weisst ja schon, bevor du in die Zeitmaschine reist, dass vor drei Jahren du selber zu dir gekommen bist und die E ist gleich im C-Quadrat gesagt hat. Genau. Das ist ja schon passiert. Genau, aber du weißt es durch dich selber, du kannst aber selber kein Wissen erlernen, du kannst selber durch dich selbst nichts erlernen und deswegen, das ist Paradox.
Knapp, man das letzte Wort!
Lass uns Wörter einfach kontinuierlich falsch aussprechen.
Diese scheiß Wörter, wir müssen uns auch was anderes überlegen, wir machen jetzt nur noch Zeichensprache. Oder wir zeichnen nur so Montagsmalermässig, zeichnen wir unsere ganzen Gags auf, glaube ich. Glaubst du, findest du generell visuelle Gags oder auditive Gags? Also auditiv im Sinne jetzt auch von Text? Besser. Vergiss es. Forget it. Nein. Diese Folge wird in die Puffopedia angehenhen als die Folge, in der wir uns am meisten versprochen haben, glaube ich.
Ja, wir sind ein bisschen aus der Übung. Kommen wir nun zum Der Podcast-Ufo-Serien-Tipp. Jede Woche empfehlen wir euch eine neue Serie, die ihr euch anschauen könnt. Wie cool. Ja, mach mal. Und zwar dieses dieses Jahr, dieses Mal, kennt wahrscheinlich schon die meisten, auf Netflix Making a Murderer eine spannende Realtime-Documentary, die ich nur aus einem Grund lustig finde. Da geht es um einen Typen, der zu Unrecht eingesperrt wird und halt irgendwie 18 Jahre lang im Gefängnis sitzt und dann wieder freikommt. Und dann wird es aber doch nochmal spannend, nur so viel gesagt. Das Lustigste allerdings fand ich an der ganzen Sache... Jetzt finde ich so lustig, du sprichst wie jemand, der für Programmzeitschriften schreibt. Und das finde ich geil, wenn man das ins echte Leben überträgt, wenn jemand nur so Geschichten erzählt, wie die in Programmzeitschriften stehen. Genau, was dann passiert, lohnt sich. Und was ich so lustig fand an der ganzen Sache, der Typ war 18 Jahre im Gefängnis und kommt dann raus. Und dieser Tag, an dem er rauskommt, wird seitdem jedes Jahr in seiner Familie riesengroß gefeiert. Seine ganze Familie schmeisst eine riesige Party, Musik, alles grossartig, wunderbar, an dem Tag, an dem er freigelassen wird. Die ganze Stadt ist happy, alle feiern, riesiges Ding. An welchem Tag wurde er freigelassen? Am 11. September. Ja, das ist jetzt ein bisschen ungünstig und ich stelle mir immer vor, wie das Ganze für Außenstehende aussehen muss.
Du fährst eine Landstrasse entlang, kommst in diesem scheiß Dorf vorbei, wo dieser fucking Redneck freigelassen wird und eine riesige Party und sie alle feiern und schießen in die Luft und Party und alle gute Laune und tanzen am 11. September. Ist halt ein bisschen blöd. Das war meine Empfehlung für Making a Murderer auf Netflix. Viel Spaß. Aber Moment mal kurz, also die Rubrik ist jetzt, wir, ist es auch lustig? Wir fehlen Serien aufgrund eines einzelnen Gags aus der Serie, der dann doch nicht so gut ist, wie man es auch hat. Aber ist der Gag jetzt wirklich, wird der auch in der Serie gemacht als Gag? Nein, natürlich nicht. Nein, wird nicht gemacht, aber es ist einfach so, nebenbei ist es am 11. September, wir feiern jedes Jahr den 11. September mit der ganzen Familie. Einfach, ich fand's lustig.
Fand ich auch lustig jetzt, aber ich dachte, ich hab die ganze Zeit auf einem anderen Prozess überlegt, was ich jetzt sagen kann für eine Serie.
Weil du hast natürlich einfach so eine Rubrikidee jetzt aus dem Boden gestampft.
Ich würde Mr. Robot empfehlen.
Ja.
Okay, nächstes Thema.
Alles klar.
Okay, ja.
Ist lustig, weil, na ja. Ja, geht schon. Da kann man jetzt viel sagen. Und Billions tatsächlich, neue Folge auf Showtime, wo jetzt die erste Folge rausgekommen ist. Und die ist dahingehend besonders, weil sie geschrieben wurde von Brian Koppelman, der einen Podcast hat über das Drehbuchschreiben, in der er jedes Mal Leute interviewt. The Moment heißt der, sehr guter Podcast. Und es ist echt ganz geil, wenn man so einen Typ lange verfolgt über diesen Podcast und dann schreibt er endlich seinen Draft und kriegt irgendwie eine Serie. Das ist echt cool. Er ist total stolz und man schaut es sich an und denkt sich nur geil, der Typ hat das geschrieben, den kenne ich schon ewig. Das ist wie wenn jetzt irgendwie ein Musical oder eine Ausstellung oder ein Museum gründen würden. Und Leute sehen es irgendwann, Florentin und Stefan präsentieren.
Das Museum ist von Stefan Tingel. Das kann doch nicht sein. Wir gehen in dieses Museum rein.
Ich glaube, das ist auch das unspektakulärste, was man machen kann. Museum. Oder?
Das war gerade das spektakulärste, was dir eingefallen ist.
Ja, Museum.
Das sagt ein bisschen was aus unserem Leben gerade im Moment.
Billions, tolle Serie. Aber man kann sich die erste Folge anschauen, die aber allerdings zensiertiert ist, dahingegen, dass alle Facks und Shits und sowas rausgeschnitten sind. Und die kriegt man nur, wenn man das Abo abschließt. Also das ist sozusagen, also habe ich das jetzt verstanden, das ist so ein Abo-Modell, du kannst dir die Folge umsonst anschauen, dann sind aber alle Facks und Shits auch rausgeschnitten, und wenn du die haben willst, dann musst du zahlen. Finde ich echt spannend. Haben wir nicht mal überlegt, oder haben wir das Off-Air überlegt, dass wir ein Abo-Modell machen, wo wir quasi die Leute die ungeschnittenen Folgen bekommen können? Das ist nicht schlecht. Oder sie können uns bezahlen dafür, dass die Folgen kürzer sind. Oder dass die Folgen eine Primzahl ergeben. Oder jeder Primzahl eine Folge machen, dass sie dann Geld bekommen. Eine Schaltjahresfolge. Sie müssen sozusagen wetten. Sie müssen wetten, wie lang die nächste Folge wird, und wer am nächsten dran ist, kriegt die nächste Folge umsonst. Oder die, die zahlen, kriegen eine kürzere Folge. Richtig, aber dafür zwei.
Aber dafür kriegen sie jede Folge zweimal.
Einmal als mp4, ohne Bild.
Und einmal als moff, als txt.
Oh, ich habe noch eine neue Rubrik.
Ja, hör mal auf, jetzt Rubriken zu erfinden die ganze Zeit.
Wir haben Januar.
Herzlich willkommen zur neuen Rubrik,
das Podcast UFO, der Relatable Moment of the Week. Mal englische Variante.
Ja, warte, ich muss kurz Leo aufmachen.
Und bitte.
Gags eingeben. Und zwar in der Relatable Moment of the Week, das sprechen wir jedes Mal über etwas, das jeder von uns so macht und wo man sich mit seinen Zuhörern etwas näher verbinden kann, denn wir alle machen verrückte Dinge und dadurch kann man gut eine persönliche Verbindung zum Zuschauer aufbauen, indem man feststellt, ha, das mache ich auch immer. Und dann mögen uns die Zuschauer mehr und haben mehr Spaß an unseren Geschichten und wir mögen uns auch mehr, weil unser Selbstbewusstsein grösser ist. Und mein relatable Moment of the Week ist, dass wenn man ein schlechtes Internet hat, dass man dann Text-Edit schliesst. Oder Mail schliesst oder irgendwelche anderen Programme schliesst, damit die Internetverbindung besser ist. So, das ist vielleicht auch mal... Ja, und vor allem den Fehler bei anderen sucht. Also den Fehler bei anderen sucht. Ich habe ein MMORPG gespielt, tatsächlich. Aha. Und ich konnte mich mit dem Server nicht verbinden und habe schon die Nummer von sämtlichen Kundenhotlines rausgesucht. Ich dachte, ich zahle dafür, dann würde ich jetzt auch, dass es funktioniert und es war einfach mein Internet, was nicht angeschlossen war. Aber man kommt da nicht drauf, weil man denkt sich, das kann es jetzt nicht sein, deswegen gucke ich da jetzt nicht nach. Das kann nicht mein Fehler sein. Man will, man will das andere schuld sind und man will die auch dafür belangen, deswegen habe ich direkt den Hörer in der Hand gehabt. Aber es lag an mir. Crazy, crazy story. Es wird lustiger, Leute, es wird noch lustiger. Es ist die erste Folge des Jahres, meine Damen und Herren. Wir sind noch ein bisschen verwirrt. Ich habe mir übrigens mal aus Spaß unser Textdokument Podcast Ideen.
Ich dachte immer, es ist die erste Folge im neuen Jahr, wir sind beide noch so ein bisschen im Winterschlaf befindlich, ein bisschen Hilfe beschaffen einfach von unserem damaligen Ichs. Und dann bin ich mal in die Vergangenheit gereist und habe geguckt, was wir so aufgeschrieben haben. Wo ist das denn nochmal? Und ich werde mir irgendwo auf der ersten Ebene in unserer Dropbox, glaube ich, und ich werde jetzt einfach mal zwischendurch, wenn wir keine Ideen mehr haben, was wir sagen können, weil wir beide irgendwie ein langweiliges Leben führen, einfach so ein paar Dinge raushauen, wie zum Beispiel, der Emu ist ausgestorben. Das war eine Idee von mir, und zwar, dass man, ja, das ist, das sind so Dinge, die funktionieren, die funktionieren in privaten Dropbox. Ob nicht. Nein, so im Sinne von Schlagzeilen, nein, das steht aber unter der Rubrik Schlagzeilen, dass wir immer Schlagzeilen haben. Nein, Themenideen. Ja, aber unter dem Schlagwort Schlagzeilen, dass wir eine Folge lang so lauter Schlagzeilen haben, als wären wir in der Zeitung. Ach so, war das nicht so schlecht. Schizophren. Der Emo ist ausgestorben. Ja, so dass man den Emo halt so behandelt, als wäre es so eine Tierart. Aber das ist so ein Lamer-Gag, der uralt ist und so schlecht. Funktioniert aber auch, weil Emo klingt wie Emu. Ja, und den haben auch schon hundert Leute gemacht, den Gag. Bin ich mir hundertprozentig zu sagen. Ach guck mal, du klaust selbst, wenn wir ihn privat... Nein, der Gag ist nicht geklaut, aber er wirkt geklaut. Und deswegen mache ich ihn nicht. Du kennst es ja auch, wenn du Gags machst und denkst,
den habe ich einfach schon hundertmal gehört,
ohne es konkret sagen zu können, wo du ihn gehört hast.
Und da bin ich auf folgende Idee gestossen,
Q&A, wir beantworten quasi Fragen, die anderen Podcasts gestellt wurden.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee. Und das sollten wir unbedingt mal machen, vielleicht nächste Woche.
Oder die nicht mal unter anderem Podcasts,
sondern generell anderen Leuten gestellt wurden.
Einfach mal generell Q&As von anderen Leuten beantworten und denen dann unsere Antworten schicken. Einfach so, hey, hier sind unsere Antworten. Guck mal drüber, vielleicht gefällt euch ja. Vielleicht nehmt ihr die ja so. Ja. Gut. Okay, dann haben wir es doch. Also das Dokument ist voll, also nicht, dass jetzt nur zwei Gags drinstehen. Wir wollen häppchenweise Dinge rausgeben.
Ja, wie gesagt, Unscheiß, also ich weiß nicht, du hast ja nie quasi was gelernt, richtig, ne?
Du hast ein Semester Philosophie studiert, zwei Semester und ich bin so ein bisschen sauer die ganze Zeit auf dich, weil ich mir denke, du machst gerade nichts und du hast auch gerade Zeit, dich um so einen Podcast vorzubereiten und ich sitze den ganzen Tag und lerne und bin so ein bisschen ungeklücklich. Ja, ich bin ja auch älter als du. Ich habe das halt schon hinter mir.
Du hast nichts in der Tat, was hast du denn gelernt? Du hast niemals gelernt.
Du hast irgendwann beschlossen, dass du nicht mehr lernst.
Ich habe knallhart drei Semester Philosophie studiert. Übrigens, es ist eingefallen, weil ich habe meine Bücher ausgemistet.
Es ist mir eingefallen. die längst schwierig zu verstehen den Philosophen aller Zeiten. Er kommt völlig motiviert zu den ersten Vorlesungen und hat drei Vorlesungen dabei. Und zwar geht es um das Buch Geschichte der Philosophie. Darum geht es. Und Florentin hat sich natürlich das Buch gekauft und die ersten drei Sitzungen sitzt er dabei und liest fleißig mit und macht sich Aufzeichnungen und Notizen, denkt sich, okay, es ist alles ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen, über was die Leute da in der Sitzung reden, ist alles sehr komplex und alles und so und ich komme im Text nicht zu hundert Prozent mit, aber ich bin dabei.
Bis er dann Anfang der vierten Sitzung bemerkt, huch, Hegel hat ja nicht nur das Buch Geschichte der Philosophie, sondern auch Philosophie der Geschichte geschrieben.
Und tatsächlich hat sich Flotinville das falsche Buch gekauft, er hat nämlich Philosophie der Geschichte gekauft und hat drei Sitzungen lang nicht bemerkt, dass er das falsche Buch hat. Aber es spricht nicht für Hegel, dass er so unkreativ mit Namen umgeht und die Geschichten so austauschbar sind. Das ist der einzige Fall, wo man das einfach so drehen kann. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass dann irgendwie so andere Leute dann gesagt haben, so, ey, der Stil ist echt krass, irgendwie, da kommst du da mit? Und ich so, ja, ist schon ein bisschen schwierig, irgendwie schon ein bisschen schwer zu sagen, was er meint. Und ich lese halt gerade irgendwie die Geschichte, den Unterschied zwischen Tal und Bergackerbau der Chinesen im dritten Jahrhundert, ja, Philosophie der Geschichte. Und die schrägenden, ja, das Wahre ist das Ganze und die Dialektik der Dinge und ich so, what the fuck, wo, ich meine, ich lese hier über irgendwelche chinesischen Herrscher, ich verstehe kein Wort, drei Sitzungen lang, dreimal zwei Stunden saß ich in diesem Raum und hatte überhaupt gar keinen Plan, also so viel nur zum Thema, ich habe Philosophie studiert, also auf dem Niveau. Man muss dazu sagen, du bist der größte Hegel-Fan, den ich kenne. Das heißt jetzt nicht so viel, aber ich muss sagen, ich glaube mittlerweile, das ist eine Art irgendwie Überkompensation deiner Erfahrungen, die du mit Hegel hattest, oder? Ja, total. Er schreibt sehr kompliziert, ja, in der Tat, wenn man das falsche Buch liest, schreibt er tatsächlich sehr kompliziert. Was für ein Trottel, ey. Ich fände es rückblickend noch lustiger, wenn du erzählt hättest, man kann ja Geschichten auch ein bisschen ausschmücken. Ich kann sie auch einfach noch mal erzählen, in deiner Wahrnehmung. Dass du quasi am Ende sogar die Klausur oder die Endprüfung mit dem falschen Buch bestanden hättest. Weil das würde dann wiederum sehr gegen Hegel sprechen. Ja, das stimmt. Oder sehr für mich tatsächlich, dass ich aus einem anderen Buch trotzdem die Dinge, die er in einem viel späteren Buch beschrieben hat, trotzdem noch rauslesen kann tatsächlich. Aber das finde ich schlecht. Das sah auch zack gleich aus. Das ist ja genauso, als würde J.K. Rowling jetzt irgendwie ein Buch Potter Harry nennen. Der Ring der Herren. What? Das funktioniert hin und vorne nicht. Naja, das war ... Ich weiß nicht, du wolltest mir gerade irgendwie einen Vorwurf machen, ich hätte nicht gelernt oder was auch immer. Ja. Das ganze Leben ist ein Lernen. Und irgendwie, ja, komm, aber das ist halt geil, dass du gerade irgendwie nichts zu tun hast, das find ich schön. Ja, find ich auch geil. Ich denk gern an dich, wie du grad nichts zu tun hast und einfach Dinge machst, die dir Fun machen. Ich hab mir heute einen Adapter besorgt, mit dem ich meine Nintendo Wii an meinen neugekauften Monitor anschliessen kann, und ich werd den Rest des Monats einfach Mario Galaxy zocken. Fickt euch einfach Scheiss drauf. Also, grossartig. Aber es ist einfach Exzess, einfach mal nichts machen und das den ganzen Tag. Und sich dabei gut fühlen zu können, das ist, glaube ich, die grösste Herausforderung des modernen Menschen, nichts zu tun und kein schlechtes Gewissen zu haben. Wenn man das noch kann, glaube ich, dann kriegt man es hin. Ich habe folgende Theorie. Dann führt man ganz okayes Leben. Ich habe die Theorie, dass die meisten Menschen ziemlich dämlich sind. Wo wir gerade bei Hegel sind und so. Ja, würde ich dir jetzt zustimmen. Weil, also ich war neulich, ich hab meinen Bewohnerparkausweis verloren. So, und das ist nicht da vorgesehen, der ist nicht vorgesehen zu verlieren. Weil es gibt, bei allen Dokumenten gibt's, beim Internet kann man nachlesen, was man machen soll, wenn man den verloren hat, bei diesem Dokument gibt's das nicht. Also musste ich zum Amt und mir den neu besorgen. Und dann habe ich einfach einen Termin gemacht, weil ich dachte, das wäre ein Ding, was man normal macht. Ich war noch nicht häufig beim Amt, da habe ich einfach einen Termin gemacht. Und dann komme ich da an und es sitzen einfach wahnsinnig viele Menschen, bestimmt so 200 Menschen sitzen dann so kinomässig vor so einer Leinwand, wo dann die ganzen Zahlen abgebildet sind. Und die sitzen da wirklich teilweise einfach so zwei Stunden lang. Fasziniert von zahlen einfach es ist unfassbar lustig weil die stühle die stühle sehen halt auch so aus wie im kino und die stahlen an diese leinwand wo die ganze zeit einfach nur zahlen und unten vielen dank dass sie bei der stadt köln sind durchläuft das ist einfach die langweiligste Projektion die ich jemals gesehen habe und es sitzen 200 leute davor und bei jeder bei jeder In der Zahl geht so ein Ruck, so ein freudiges Erwarten, so ein Huschen geht durchs Publikum. Aber die gucken den langweiligsten Film der Welt. Einfach nur ab und zu, ja, und jetzt 913 und so und ich komme da rein und direkt ist meine Zahl da, weil ich gerade pünktlich einfach gekommen bin zu der Zeit, wo ich mir den Termin gemacht habe. Und es war einfach echt erstaunlich zu gucken, dass sehr viele Menschen, oder sind die nicht doof und die wollen einfach vor dieser Leinwand sitzen? Das kann ich nachvollziehen, das ist ganz geil. Ich glaube, das ist wie dieses Affenexperiment, wenn da einfach mal 20 Leute fasziniert vor der Leinwand sitzen, setzen dich die anderen Leute dazu, denken die Leinwand wäre faszinierend und so führt sich dieser Prozess immer weiter, ohne dass die Leinwand wirklich faszinierend ist. Ich glaube, du musst nur denken, etwas ist faszinierend und dann ist es schon faszinierend. Aber Menschen sind nicht nur dumm, habe ich gemerkt, sondern Menschen sind auch schwer. Also vom Gewicht her schwer. Sind ziemlich schwer. Weil ich bin nämlich nach München gefahren über die Feiertage und das war tatsächlich ein sehr interessantes Erlebnis, auch ein soziologisches Experiment in gewisser Weise, weil wir fahren dann so eine halbe Stunde und fahren dann in so einen Bahnhof ein und dann heißt die Durchsage, unser Zug ist zu schwer, wir können so nicht weiterfahren. Ja, bitte steigen Sie aus. Exakt, es müssen Leute aussteigen. Aber gibt es da so eine Art Casting oder wer muss dann aussteigen und wer darf weiterfahren? Genau, das ist die Frage. Spannend. Extrem spannend. Und vor allem auch, erstens, vorher merkt der Schaffner, macht das wirklich so einen Unterschied? Weil ich meine, was wiegt denn so ein fucking ICE? Bestimmt einige Tonnen. Und dann diese paar Menschen da, ist doch scheißegal. Also komisch. Aber wahrscheinlich ist der Bremsweg zu weit oder sowas. Ich wäre gern mal in so einem Cockpit. Weil was ist da? Die haben auch ein Lenkrad oder so, wo ich mich auch mal frage, es fährt auf Schienen. Aber Zug fährt doch auf Schienen. Nee, nee, nee, das sind keine Schienen. Nein, nein, nein. Warum haben die Lenkrad? Es ist eine Straße tatsächlich, es ist eine Straße. Ich finde das sehr spannend, warum Züge Lenkrad haben. Deswegen entgleisen die ja manchmal, weil da einfach mal links und zack haben die. Aber das war tatsächlich sehr interessant, weil natürlich wollte niemand aussteigen. Und ist halt so irgendwie 500 Leute in dem ICE und 50 müssen aussteigen, niemand will dazugehören und es gibt kein System wirklich, nach dem jetzt selektiert wird. So, und da hieß es dann so, ja, jeder der steht, der keinen Sitzplatz hat, weil der Zug war auch ziemlich voll, jeder der steht muss aussteigen, aber auch die, die standen, wollten nicht aussteigen, das war echt so interessant, und dann dachte ich mir, ich mal so reingerufen, ja, wir können ja auch alle irgendwie Sport machen und abnehmen. Habe ich nicht, war nicht so gut. Weil ich dachte mir, anstatt dass Leute aussteigen, jeder, anstatt dass fünf Prozent aussteigen, kann auch jeder fünf Prozent abnehmen. Das war vielleicht einfacher werden. Aber da dachte ich mir wirklich, okay, was passiert jetzt? Ich habe mich schon irgendwie so als Kommissar angeboten, der da durch die Leute geht und selektiert und die fetten Leute rausschmeißt, finde ich richtig gut, richtig gut gefunden. Und dich selber rausschmeißt dann und der Zugführer sich einfach freiwillig dazu bereit erklärt, rauszusteigen. Genau, aber das ist natürlich interessant, weil da kommt es dann wirklich zu so einer Säuberungsaktion und da wird es auch wirklich politisch plötzlich so. Wer muss jetzt gehen aus so einer Gesellschaft? Also es müssen Leute gehen, aber niemand will gehen, und irgendwas muss passieren.
Und es bilden sich auch immer so Schlaumeier raus,
die so superschlaue Sprüche haben wie
sind wir zu schwer oder ist der Zug zu schwach?
Und dann die Leute nicken zustimmend und so.
Aber wenn dann mal jemand so eine Idee bringt wie,
ja dann überlegen wir uns jetzt halt einfach irgendein Kriterium,
sagen wir jetzt mal halt Juden,
sagen wir jetzt mal einfach mal alle Juden steigen aus,
damit wir halt einfach irgendwas haben, dann ist das Geschrei wieder riesengroß und hier und da, aber irgendwas muss passieren tatsächlich. Aber es hat ewig lang gedauert natürlich, weil niemand aussteigen wollte. Und tatsächlich kam dann auch ein anderer Zug, der den dann mitgenommen hat, die anderen, ich weiß nicht, nach Auschwitz, nach Auschwitz, genau, ja, tatsächlich. Und dann ging das alles relativ flott dann tatsächlich, als sich dann auch ein paar Leute bereit erklärt haben, da mitzuhelfen. Da war dann die Bereitschaft relativ groß. Und ja, so ist es passiert tatsächlich. Aber total spannend eigentlich. Aber ECE tatsächlich wird immer mehr zu meiner Heimat. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mal beobachtet habt. Aber wenn man... Oh, jetzt wird wieder observational für Orentin. Observational! Oh, da bin ich immer alles gespannt, was er da beobachtet hat. Oh, pack das Fernglas aus, schliess das Monokel an, jetzt wird wieder weit und scharf geschaut. Weil gerade so wenig passiert in meinem Leben, denke ich mir auch immer. In gewisser Weise sind Anekdoten Dinge, die einem passieren, in gewisser Weise auch Dinge, die man selber in der Welt vermutet zu entdecken. Und das finde ich jetzt ganz spannend, was du jetzt genau entdeckt hast. Wir schauen mal kurz rein. Also, wenn man nämlich zum Beispiel im ICE mit einem Podcar, äh, Pod, äh, wir fangen nochmal an. Wir hören, wir hören Florentin, wie er seine Anekdote vorträgt. Viel Spaß. Es war später Dezember. Florentin Will sass mal wieder alleine im ICE. Und ich habe Podcast gehört mit mit meinem iPhone und ich dachte mir, oh, iPhone ist ja immer so eine kritische Sache, Akku hier und da, schließe ich es mal lieber an und es gibt ja im ICE so Steckdosen und ich weiß nicht, ob es euch mal aufgefallen ist, passt da mal ganz auf, Leute, es ist ein Klangerlebnis, wenn man nämlich gleichzeitig im ICE seinen iPhone auflädt und die Kopfhörer eingestellt hat, hört man so ein Surren, wie die Hochspannungsleitung. Du hörst den ICE denken. Exakt genau das. Genau das war nämlich mein Punkt. Es hat sich so ein bisschen angefühlt, als hätte man so eine Connection, weil es ist nicht so ein durchgehendes Surren, sondern es ist so ein So wirklich wie eine Sprache. Nein, nicht schon wieder Wuppertal, ich hasse Wuppertal. Ihr seid so scheiße Schwäger, ihr Pfeiler, nehmt doch mal ab, fickt euch. Es müssen Leute raus, es müssen Leute raus. Ich halte dir an, ich halte dir jetzt hier an. Nur noch drei Jahre bis zur Rente. Voller Wut. Und es ist so interessant, weil man wirklich das Gefühl hat, diese Maschine würde zu einem kommunizieren. Es ist auch so ein bisschen Avatar, ne? Dieses Zusammenstecken von Dingen und dann plötzlich ist man mit dem Ding verbunden. Ja, man muss nur genug Dinge verbinden und es entsteht ein Bewusstsein. Das glaube ich auch. Weißt du, so eine Ameise an sich ist scheiße, aber nimm mal tausend und die arbeiten zusammen und plötzlich entsteht sowas wie eine Persönlichkeit, wie Bewusstsein. Ein Hügel, wie so ein random Hügel. Ein Hügel, ja. Wer hätte das gedacht? Hügel. Boah, ich weiß noch. Ich weiß, wie die Folge nennen. Hegel und Hügel.
Mega gut!
Ich hab mal als Kind,
das ist, glaube ich, das befriedigendste
Erlebnis aller Zeiten. Ich hab mal als Kind
war ich in der Badewanne.
Nein, ich hatte mal als Kind
hatte ich mal so eine sadistische Phase,
glaube ich hat jeder, wo jemand einfach Tiere umbringt.
Ja, hatte ich auch. Ich denke sehr oft, ich habe ein Schmetterling mit einem Badmintenschläger einfach erschlagen. Aber das passt halbwegs. Das passt halt auch gar nicht in mein Leben. Weißt du was? Also ich habe jetzt folgendes Bild von mir. Man denkt ja auch nur an solche Dinge, kann man ja zurück sich erinnern. Und ich habe jetzt folgendes Bild von mir. Ich schlafe die meiste Zeit des Tages und die andere Zeit töte ich Schmetterling mit einem Badmintenschläger. Das ist das Bild, was ich vor mir habe. Aber eine gute Waffe, oder? Badminschläger ist eine gute Waffe für Fleder. Ach Mann, ey, Schmetter, Flederschmetterling. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, das war das Befriedensteil des Lebens und das ist immer noch so ein Gefühl. Es gibt so manche so ganz befriedigende Dinge, wenn du so einen Pickel ausdrückst oder irgendwie so, wenn irgendwas genau passt oder so der Joghurt- Deckel oder so alles genau abreddet. Egal. Auf jeden Fall habe ich... Du hast massive Wortfindungsstörungen. Ich habe Ameisen getötet. Ja, ich bin auch kurz vor dem Schlaganfall. Ich habe dieser gesamte Starkstrom, der mit dem ICE ununterbrochen durch die Synapsen gejagt wird, ist glaube ich nicht so ideal. Auf jeden Fall habe ich Ameisen getötet und ich bin in den Wald gegangen und habe da einen Ameisenhügel gefunden und in Wäldern, boah, da gibt es manchmal fucking Ameisenhügel, also riesengroß. Und da habe ich eine Deodose genommen und Feuerzeug und dann habe ich so ein Loch im Ameisenhügel gefunden und dann habe ich da so die Deoflasche drangehalten, Feuerzeug und dann kann man halt so eine Stichflamme erzeugen, wie so ein Flammenwerfer. Und dann habe ich da die Flamme reingeschossen in diesen Ameisenhügel und überall in dem gesamten Ameisenhügel aus ganz vielen kleinen Löchern kamen überall kleine Flammen raus. What? Und ich wusste einfach, alles da drin ist tot. Alles. Jede fucking Ameise ist tot. Es ist wahnsinnig befremdlich,
aber schon irgendwie ganz cool, dass überall
Flammen rauskommen. Es ist richtig cool.
Wie kann das denn sein?
Das Gas sich da einfach überall ausbreitet.
Und es ist ja ein komplettes Netz, das ist ja ein
durchgängeverbundenes Netz, wo überall
die Verbindung ist. Aber so funktionieren
Flammenwerfer, so kannst du einen Bunker ausrotten.
Indem du einfach in die Bunkeranlage
einen Flammenwerfer reinballerst und alles, was da drin ist, ist tot, weil die Flammen halt auch um die Ecken gehen und halt die Leerräume ausfüllen. Das ist ja die Idee eines Flammenwerfers zum Beispiel. Und so habe ich zum Beispiel diesen gesamten fucking Ameisenhügel vernichtet. Krass. Und dieser Anblick, wo plötzlich überall, wie so eine Erdbeere, wo sie lauter die Samen ausnehmen, so ganz viele kleine Flämmchen, diesen Ameisenhügel und da drin war alles tot.
Da habe ich mich schon ein bisschen schlecht gefühlt, weil ich nicht dachte, dass ich so eine effektive Kampfmaschine bin, aber hat funktioniert. Und seitdem führen die Ameisen aus Ebersbach einen Kriegstück gegen dich. Ja genau, die, die überlebt haben, die die Geschichte erzählen. Die die Geschichte an Enkeln auch erzählen. Das große Flammenmassaker von 2003. Genau, eine Ameise kam gerade von der Arbeit zurück mit einem Zehn-Kilo-Blatt auf dem Rücken und so, Leute, Leute. Mama, heute war doch dein Geburtstag. Das war der 11. September. Aber es riecht gut. Habt ihr gekocht? Was ist los? So was, solche Gags könnte man noch einbauen. Naja, auf jeden Fall. Oh, zum Thema ICE hören, tatsächlich ist es tatsächlich ganz spannend, kann man machen, hört mal rein. Aber wie du schon gesagt hast, es ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte, so mit Dingen kommunizieren zu können, mit denen man eigentlich gar nicht kommunizieren kann. Vielleicht fehlt einem einfach nur das Bewusstsein. Ich bin gerade so einsam, ich bin ja auch, ich weiß nicht, so ein bisschen wie Disturbia hier. Was ist denn los bei dir? Ja, ich sitze hier rum und schneide ... Kein Kontakt, nichts macht nichts, das ist nur Stefan. Ich sitze hier gerade einfach tagelang in dieser Wohnung und schreibe Essays, weil ich das muss und es ist wahnsinnig langweilig und ich sitze hier und das ist so ein bisschen Disturbia-mäßig so und dann habe ich einfach mal sehr lange mit Siri gesprochen. Was machst du denn, Mathe oder was schreibst du für Essays? Oder so Schlagwortgeschichten, mehr von den ... Reizwortgeschichten, ganz viel Aliens, ganz viel Guido. Die Dorsons, genau, die Dorsons schlagen zurück. Wir können ja mal gegenseitig ein Essay von uns vorlesen. Du liest einen von mir vor und ich von dir. Wir machen die Essay-Folge. Aber nicht aktuelle Essays. Nee, da muss uns so ein gutes Wortspiel einfallen. Essay, can you believe it? Nope, funktioniert nicht. You don't essay. Essay my name. Essay no more. Ja, halt alles mit say, ne? Ja, korrekt. Wir haben es durch, ja, es reicht, danke. Was wolltest du sagen? Essay like Sunday morning, sowas vielleicht? Naja. Nee, aber habe ich tatsächlich letztens auch noch eine ICE-Geschichte, es tut mir leid, dass alle meine Geschichten heute aus dem ICE kommen. Ist ja schön, wenn es heute wäre, aber naja, gut, ich ist ein bisschen deine Persona, so einfach ICE-Geschichten. ICE, ICE Baby könnte man die Folge auch nennen. Ja, können wir gerne machen. Ähm, und da war so ein kleines Mädchen wie ihr zu ihr und das hatte so einen Bären dabei, einen Braunbären.
Und der ist ihr runtergefallen und dann stand ein Mann hinter ihr, der hat den Bären aufgehoben, hat den aber so im Gesicht angepackt. Also so wirklich so mit der rechten Faust, so richtig ins Gesicht reingefasst. So, und er hat ihm das mitgegeben und ich habe das beobachtet und ich fand das für einen kurzen Moment so unhöflich, so unglaublich befremdlich, dass der dem so in das Gesicht reingreift. Man ist natürlich scheißegal, das ist nur ein Stoffding, aber trotzdem, dass der da keinen Respekt dafür hat und hat das dem Mädchen gegeben und das Mädchen hat auch total befremdlich, fast gruselig ihn angeguckt, so, danke, so und hat sich gar nicht so sehr um den Bären Sorgen gemacht, als war traurig, dass er den Bären so grob angefasst hat. Also ganz, ganz seltsam. Natürlich nette Geste von dem Herrn, aber also Leute, da müsst ihr auch ein bisschen aufpassen, dass man da Sachen richtig macht. Und jetzt müssen wir mal kurz diese Geschichte irgendwie ins Leben transferieren. Wir müssen da jetzt mal kurz so eine Transferleistung hinbekommen, dass man sagt, wofür steht das, wofür kann das in deinem Leben stehen. Das steht dafür, dass Dinge nicht durch ihre Materialität ausgezeichnet werden, sondern doch auch durch ihren ideellen Wert, was sie für Leute bedeuten. Oder auch ein bisschen empathisch sein mal. Ja, es ist ja genau wie die ICE-Geschichte. So eine ICE hat auch Gefühle, natürlich nicht, aber wir sind menschliche Wesen und denken Gefühle in alles Mögliche rein. Und auch in diesem Bern, und das ist eine Fähigkeit, die wertvoll ist und die man nicht verlieren darf. Und wo man auch als Erwachsener manchmal mit den Augen eines Kindes Dinge angucken können und sagen kann, hm, das ist ein Ameisenberg, vielleicht müssen die alle sterben, vielleicht will Gott, dass ich die alle töte. Es ist fast Ende der Folge und ich wollte es vorher nicht ansprechen, würde es aber jetzt gerne machen. Hast du bei der Folge jetzt darauf geachtet, dass du möglichst wenig und möglichst selten sowas wie weird und creepy sagst? Ich habe sogar aktiv den Relatable Moment of the Week eingeführt, der komplett englisch war. Es hat jemand kommentiert, dass wir zu oft diese Wörter benutzen und und ich bin so beeinflussbar, dass ich es natürlich nicht mehr mache, weil es fällt, auch wenn ich jetzt alte Folgen höre, es würde mir auffallen, es würde mich nerven, ich würde sagen, was für ein Idiot bin ich, dass ich das annauend sage. Es hat jemand sich beschwert, dass wir creepy und weird und what und so oft sagen, und hat natürlich auch recht mit. Ja, ich habe mir überlegt, ob wir da drauf einge sollen und wie tatsächlich, weil, also, ne, vielen Dank für diesen Kommentar, aber allein meine Erfahrung heraus, die unangenehmsten Menschen der Welt sind Leute, die sich darüber beschweren, wie Leute reden. Es tut mir wirklich leid an der Stelle und nichts gegen dich natürlich, aber du bist Teil einer extrem unbeliebten Gruppe, das muss dir klar sein.
Du bist vielleicht cool, ein toller Typ, aber Leute, die das machen, was du machst, sind schlimmer als Hitler. So, das nur vorneweg. Sind schlimmer als Teddybären ins Gesicht Grapscher. Zum Beispiel. Auf einer Ebene. Wann hat es denn jemals funktioniert, dass du jemandem sagst, er soll so und so sprechen, und es hat tatsächlich funktioniert. Wo man tatsächlich mal sagt, ich finde es scheiße, dass die Jugend jetzt cool sagt, anstatt Astrein. Es hat nie funktioniert. Was übrigens der beste Schritt der Menschheit war, dass man sich von Astrein gelöst hat. Das war eines der Dinge, die wir verloren haben zum Glück. Weil ich habe überlegt, ich habe das oft schon mal gedacht,
und oft schon mal war ich kurz davor, diesen Wunsch zu formulieren bei anderen. Ich wusste aber, dass sie da niemals drauf eingehen werden. Ich kann einen Luriot nicht ändern, dass er bitte anders gucken soll. Aber, gut, dass ich mich jetzt mit Luriot vergleiche, aber ich gehe da einfach drauf ein jetzt und ich erf erfülle diesen Wunsch und ich werde es nicht mehr sagen. Und das finde ich auch eine Stärke, zu sagen, ich gestehe mir diesen Fehler ein und werde jetzt nicht mehr so reden. Sprache entwickelt sich ganz natürlich und jeder versucht. Aber wir stumpfen dann die Sprache ab, wenn wir nur ein Wort nur noch benutzen. Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht. Wenn die Folgen nur noch aus dem What, What, What gestehen. Nein, warum, das kann ja auch als Running Gag irgendwie bereichernd sein oder als Wiederkehrendes Element und so. Das ist ja, Wiederholung ist ja per se jetzt nicht unbedingt negativ. Nein. Sprache entwickelt sich immer weiter und jeder Wunsch, Sprache zu ändern, ist immer konservativ und rückständig. Immer, weil es einfach der natürliche Gang einer Sprache ist, sich zu erzählen, was ich schon mir für Nächächte um die Ohren gehauen habe, wegen dieser Scheiss ergibt Sinn, macht Sinn scheiße, ey. Wenn noch einer sagt, es macht nur Unsinn, es macht nicht Sinn, man fickt dich. Wenn man darauf achtet, auch mit etwas ist schwer, etwas ist schwierig, wenn man da die ganze Zeit darauf achtet, dann ist man nur noch am Nachdenken, dann kann man gar nicht mehr richtig reden. Vor allem ist es nichts, Sprache ist dafür da, dass man sie verändert und sich anpasst und sie mit Leben erfüllt und genau dafür ist sie da und es gibt kein richtig und falsch. Im Duden stehen auch nur Dinge drin, die Leute sagen, es gibt kein System dahinter und da steht auch Macht Sinn drin, einfach weil die Leute es sagen, weil der Usus, also das Verwenden von Usus, für meine guten Freunde. Die höchste Maxime ist.
So, an der Stelle.
Dankeschön für diesen.
Tut mir leid, tut mir leid.
Nein, es ist vielleicht eine Sturheit, aber es ist einfach ein Unternehmen, das immer scheitert, Sprache zu ändern.
Es scheitert immer.
Sprache muss atmen.
Auch mal, weißt du?
Auch mal gegen die Windrichtung.
Ja, und auch mal ohne ... Sprechen wir einfach mal. Ja, es war die erste Folge des Jahres. Wollen wir eine kurze Nachbesprechung machen? Sorry. Wollen wir uns ein bisschen an Schulz und Böhrmann anlehnen und eine Nachbesprechung machen? Also, ich fand tatsächlich, der Anfang war ein bisschen komisch tatsächlich, weil wir so ein bisschen reinkommen mussten. Es fühlt sich, da hat man zum ersten Mal wieder gemerkt, wie komisch das eigentlich ist, was wir da machen, dass wir jede Woche aus unserem Leben erzählen. Und wie komisch es einem vorkommt, wenn man das lange nicht gemacht hat. Ja klar, natürlich. Gut, dann machen wir das gut. Kauft weiterhin fröhlich unsere T-Shirts, besucht die Pufopedia und schaut mal auf Facebook und Twitter vorbei. Da könnt ihr immer die neuesten Informationen abgreifen. Wir sind auch so ein bisschen im, sagen wir mal, im Warmmach-Modus. Wir haben uns so ein bisschen die Hände gerieben, oder? Wir haben uns die Hände ein bisschen gerieben. Ja, ich sehe jetzt aber nicht, dass es groß ist, über Twitter irgendwas rauszuhauen, so Gag-Feuerberg-mäßig, sondern so ein bisschen locker mal anfangen. Es geht langsam wieder los. Haben wir diese Phase nicht einfach schon erfüllt, so dieses, wir müssen uns beweisen, wir müssen den Leuten zeigen, wir müssen immer krampfhaft alles rausholen. Sind wir nicht schon durch, sind nicht die Leute, die jetzt uns noch zuhören? Nee, wahrscheinlich ist genau das der Fehler, genau das der Punkt, an dem Projekte scheiße werden. Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, an welchem Punkt man sich auf das, was man bisher geleistet hat, einfach ausruht. Ich glaube, der Punkt ist noch nicht ganz da, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Aber entweder, ich glaube, jetzt kommt entweder so sehr erwachsen, entweder das war jetzt so, das letzte Jahr war so die Pubertät, so wir haben gekämpft und wir sind gewachsen und jetzt irgendwie haben Stress gehabt und jetzt kommt entweder das Erwachsensein, das entweder mega langweilig wird oder richtig interessant, kommt ein bisschen darauf an. Oder wir machen einfach weiter Pubertät. Ja, oder wir experimentieren so ein bisschen. Wir experimentieren ein bisschen an uns herum gegenseitig. Lernen unseren Körper kennen und so. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Alles klar. Ich wünsche dir eine schöne Woche. Wir werden uns dann glücklich zum nächsten Mal wiederhören. Und ich bin gespannt, was du erlebst. Liebe Grüße an die Hörer, viel Spaß, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Einen Hutstart ins neue Jahr wünschen, Florian.
Das sollten wir lassen im nächsten Mal.
Ja, das gefällt mir nicht, das würde ich ändern.